good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight there's a lot about
modern economic theory that's important
but difficult to understand in fact many
people formulating these theories don't
really understand them and that's why
they can never explain anything clearly
but there is one core economic fact that
everybody even those of us with poor
math skills grasp instantly and that's
when we're getting poorer how do you
know when you're getting poor well you
know you're getting poor when you don't
have enough money to do the things that
you once did you are moving backward it
is a very scary feeling
short of armed robbery nothing makes
americans poorer faster than inflation
does
now finance moguls who borrow money for
a living love inflation it makes their
debt cheaper it's a good thing for them
but everyone else hates it because it
crushes them in ways that are very
obvious day-to-day
so with that in mind the new inflation
numbers are out and they're the worst
this country has seen in nearly 40 years
according to consumer price index
inflation is up almost seven percent
over the past 12 months it's very high
the problem is
the reality is much worse than that and
that's because the consumer index is
useless as a guide to life in america
doesn't actually measure the cost of
living in that way it is a lie it's a
rigged government number one of many
now the cpi is calculated by assigning
relative weight to different categories
of goods it's a very complex series of
formulas some of them were formulated in
good faith others were designed to
deceive you
but in effect the bottom line is the cpi
does a very bad job of measuring how
much it actually costs to live in this
country for example gas prices
in the cpi gas prices constitute less
than four percent of the total value of
the products included
now that's realistic if you happen to
live in say manhattan where pretty much
nobody drives a car
but if you have a car and you drive more
than a few miles to work every day
that's ridiculous because for you gas
prices are a far larger part of your
budget and yet all of this is ignored by
the cpi
you don't need to be an economist to
understand this
the bottom line is these are not
accurate numbers
but they were put together by people who
we consider very smart so you have to
ask yourself why are these numbers
inaccurate think about it the consumer
price index measures the downside of
federal economic policy
so let's say you printed too many u.s
dollars you wanted to fund useless
programs and pay off your donors now if
you did that you would devalue your own
currency you would cause inflation over
time you would impoverish your own
population
those would be the effects but of course
you would want to hide those effects
you'd instead want to tell everybody
that thanks to you the economy is great
and the consumer price index allows
politicians to do that
the cpi allows reckless economically
illiterate leaders to hide the mess they
have made
it's a conflict of interest if there
ever was one it's like putting bernie
madoff in charge of the audit committee
what do you think is going to happen if
you do that
fake numbers allow fake economists to
tell a fake story about what's actually
happening to the country and they've
definitely been doing that
our economists have conveyed that
they feel that the impact of our
proposals will be transitory all of the
economists
that the president has been relying on
suggest that there is a transitory
nature nature to the inflation
problem economists call all these things
transitory effects this inflation uh
that we're experiencing is transitory it
is not going to be here long we've had
several months of high inflation
that um
most economists including me believe
will be transitory we don't expect that
those
that upward pressure will produce
substantially higher prices or that the
effects will be persistent we expect
that they'll be transitory or temporary
the usual cavalcade of liars and dumb
people maxine waters on economic policy
please stay in your lane but the last
guy is regarded as very smart his name
is jerome powell he is believe it or not
the chairman of the federal reserve
powell has now updated his assessment
transitory after weeks of being laughed
at he no longer uses that word
transitory to describe inflation quote i
think it's probably a good time to
retire that word powell said
too late jerome no one believes you
anymore no one ever did who's paying
attention
in fact there's only one accurate way to
measure inflation and somehow the fed
has not yet figured this out here it is
you ask yourself
what does it cost you to live in this
country compared to what it cost you a
year ago it's not complicated do the
math and you will see that the actual
number the rise in inflation is not even
close to the seven percent that
washington is claiming
in the last year the price of a used car
for example has gone up by more than 30
percent beef prices have risen by 21
crude oil up 55 dimensional lumber 35
wheat 37 sugar 33 corn 39
palm oil 43
do you drink coffee in the morning ever
oh too bad
the price of coffee has risen 108
percent in the last year do you like
breakfast cereal oh sorry oats are up
114
and those are the numbers you see on the
label at the grocery store
in addition to conventional inflation
consumers also face widespread shrink
flation that's an informal term that
economics economists use for the stealth
shrinking of consumer products so
companies sell you less for the same
price
have you bought a snickers bar recently
if it seems a lot smaller than it used
to that's because it is
and those are the products you buy
most people in this country still live
indoors and the cost of living indoors
has risen dramatically
rents in southern california for example
have tripled in a single year as this
recent fox package reports
inflation and migration people from l.a
and orange county moving to the inland
empire in search of affordable housing
are two reasons for the booming real
estate market and the high rents in the
inland empire some landlords have more
than tripled rent prices in the last
year an apartment that is in not great
area of redlands it used to go for 800 a
month
and we just noticed that it was up for 2
600 per month space hasn't changed you
know it's like a two
bedroom apartment with barely any
livable space
twenty six hundred dollars per month for
a depressing little unit in a deeply
crummy part of the state that cost 800
bucks a year ago
so that's what was going on in this
country when jerome powell and joe biden
were telling you that inflation was
transitory these people don't buy things
or they just lying
either way everybody else knows exactly
what's going on because it's impossible
to ignore
americans are seeing the side effects of
inflation in their budgets general mills
even announcing they're raising the
prices of some of their cereals by up to
20 percent the grand total of our
thanksgiving dinner was 51 dollars 25
cents more than 20 percent over last
year's list the dollar tree is hiking
its prices from one dollar to a dollar
25 for most items if you're lucky enough
to find ammo you'll pay more for it this
on the store shelf for about 60 65 cents
around when
this would be normally somewhere around
20 you know low 20 something cents
around pizzerias across the five
boroughs are rising the price of a slice
dollar slices are now up to a dollar and
fifty cents those who heat with oil will
need to dig deeper this year the average
homeowner is probably going to pay about
500 more for the heating season than
they did a year ago
oh
so tell us again joe biden how inflation
is at seven percent read some more
government numbers to us
one group that would never even consider
believing numbers like these crap like
this is investors
they're not looking at the consumer
price index they do this for a living
and they know exactly what dangerous
inflation looks like and that's why
they're buying hard assets
you see it everywhere the median sales
price of an existing single family home
in austin texas increased 33 and a half
percent
in a single year
the median price of a condo around miami
has gone up nearly 21 now real estate in
dade county was already wildly
overheated now it's a bonfire
why is that happening
simple investors are afraid
consider equities prices the s p 500 is
up 28
in the last year now if you're looking
for the real inflation rate that's a lot
closer than the cpi is going to get you
but if you want to know what people who
think about money for a living really
think about the economy and the value of
the u.s dollar
look at the value of cryptocurrency
cryptocurrency is by definition a refuge
from inflation people buy bitcoin when
they decide the us dollar is no longer
safe
what's happened in bitcoin it's up 164
in the past year ethereum and other
cryptocurrencies up 622
so you should consider that a referendum
on the strength of our economic system
as judged by the people who know the
system best because that's exactly what
it is
so these are major changes to the us
economy and they're very ominous for
financial journalists there is no bigger
story right now than this what we just
said
and yet amazingly these shameless hacks
are studiously ignoring it
here's cnbc's eternal financial genius
telling us that in fact under joe biden
we're now entering a new economic golden
age watch to me we have the strongest
economy perhaps i have ever seen shed
number this morning unemployment are
it's the best in years not best in 69.
we have all spotted the endless help
wanted signs the housing apartment
shortages the tremendous demand for
goods and services a marvel to behold
oh people are confident about their jobs
i say fantastic and the ability to even
get better ones if they want to they're
spending more than i've ever seen but
they're doing it with cash not on credit
they're doing so
in a roaring 20 style
imagine believing that that was jim
cramer of cnbc
so we see that tape how should we feel
about jim cramer's assessment of our
economy
well it may be a little bit early to
apply for a foreign passport but it's
not a good sign not at all it was jim
cramer you remember who told you to buy
bear stearns a few days before it
disappeared completely
should i be worried about bear stearns
in terms of liquidity and get my money
out there no
no no bear stearns is fine do not take
your money out this is real if there's
one takeaway other than plus 400
somebody bear stearns is not in trouble
i mean if anything they're more likely
to be taken over
don't move your money from fair that's
just being silly don't be silly bear
stearns is not in trouble no no no bear
stearns is fine
do not take your money out
that's what he said right before the
crash now in a normal country with a
functioning meritocracy anyone who said
something like that would no longer be
touting stocks on television he'd be
cleaning your pool assuming he could
muster the skills to do that
and yet there he is the same man still
televised a living testament to our
leader's suicidal tendency to reward
failure
or consider andrew ross sorkin his
bosses consider him the smartest man on
cnbc in fact he's about as bright as jim
cramer is but much oilier
sorkin's view is that we ought to be
grateful for inflation you'll be
thankful to joe biden quote
inflation has long been seen as the
economic villain that view is changing
for those who worry about growing
inequality inflation might actually be a
salve up to a point
oh thank you andrew ross so we're
becoming venezuela
but that's a good thing because your
neighbor is going to be every bit as
poor as you are
so that's the current state of the
cutting edge of financial journalism in
this country hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else